[Music]
a significant part of the action and
events in ursula k le guin's second
earth sea novel the tombs of ottawa
is happening exactly underneath those
tombs these massive
monoliths that have been there for time
immemorial and which are the domain of
the
ancient ones the ancient powers of the
earth that are called the nameless ones
the uh
masters that are serves as a priestess
and she gets to know her domain and we
as the readers get to know it
as the chapters progress there's a very
important developmental
exposition that's taking place and
interestingly she has to learn about
this although she is the reincarnation
of the previous priestess she has to
learn about it from the two
other priestesses not the priestesses of
the nameless ones but uh those of the
god king and of the twin brothers who
have been told by the previous arja you
need to tell my successor this and this
and this and this and they've memorized
all of that and castle is going to lead
her
into the under tomb so that she can
administer
some of her duties and get to know
her domain and so over time
uh our arha is going to do this it
begins with the sacrifice of prisoners
who have been sent by the god king
and before that um there's this exchange
between arja and her eunuch
manon so she says
here we go a little bit earlier um
there are riches there thar tells me
about them sometimes enough to fill the
god king's temple 10 times over gold and
trophies given ages ago 100 generations
who knows how long
they're all locked away in the pits and
vaults underground they won't take me
there yet they keep me waiting and
waiting but i know what it's like there
are rooms underneath the hall underneath
the whole place under where we stand now
there's a great maze of tunnels a
labyrinth it's like a great dark city
under the hill full of gold and the
swords of old heroes and old crowns and
years and silence
she spoke as if in trance in rapture and
so what's going on there she's she's
going off of the
stories of what's underneath her
imaginations
she has not yet encountered the
realities
so um
he says
well you're mistress of all that the
silence and the dark and she says i am
but they won't show me anything only the
rooms above ground behind the throne
they haven't even shown me the entrances
to the places underground they just
mumble about them sometimes they're
keeping my own domain for me why do they
make me wait and wait and manan says
well you're young and perhaps they're
afraid little one it's not their domain
after all it's yours they're in danger
when they enter there there's no mortal
that doesn't fear the nameless ones and
this is worth spending a little bit of
time on as we find out in the story
there are places that
some people can go to for example these
eunuchs no man is supposed to be in
there but priestesses
and eunuchs can go in but only so far
so for example within the labyrinth
indeed the priestesses and the eunuchs
can go in there but there is a room the
great treasure room that only
our huh is supposed to be able to go
into anybody who else who goes in there
may never come out as a matter of fact
once the door is closed to the labyrinth
it's pretty difficult to get out as well
and why because the old powers
don't want people
in their domains they don't want them
committing sacrilege they
tolerate the priestess they tolerate the
eunuchs doing things they consume the
sacrifices that are made to them and
they also consume all the thieves who
have come in to try to
steal bits of the treasure
so um
as we go on
castle says one of my mistresses duties
is the sacrifice of certain prisoners
criminals of noble birth who by
sacrilege treason of sinned against our
lord the god-king or against the
nameless one said arha truly now it is
not fitting that the eaten one while you
had a child should undertake this duty
but my mistress is no longer a child
there are prisoners in the room of
chains sent a month ago by the grace of
our lord the god king from his city
awabath
and so now is when she's being initiated
and it's because
of these prisoners who have to be
sacrificed in the room of chains the
room of chains is as you could guess a
room in which people are chained up and
essentially kept there in this case
they'll be kept there until they die in
uncomfortable positions
and then they'll be buried uh and eaten
by the nameless ones in what is called
the under tomb and so there's this
exposition of the the room of chains
which is set off from the undertomb and
then there's the under tomb itself and
the undertomb is this vast
cavern underneath the
tombs
so
there's some uh discussion here
arja has a set of keys right and
uh as as a uh castle says my mistress
has the keys to all the dark places
since the coming of her age uh r had
worn on her belt an iron ring on which
held a little dagger and 13 keys some
long and heavy some small as fish hooks
that one castle said pointing and placed
her thick forefinger on a crevice
between two red pitted rock surfaces the
key opens up the
rock face and they enter into it
it was absolutely black there was no
light the dark seemed to press like welt
fat
like wet felt on the open eyes
they crouched almost doubled over for
the place they stood in was not four
feet high
did you bring a light she whispered as
one does in the dark i brought no light
castle replied behind her
and then they they move on and they are
in this vast cavern
araha says here we must be beneath the
stones
and then castle says yes this is the
under tomb go on i cannot stay here
follow the wall to the left past three
openings and arhas says i shall come
here with a torch
light is forbidden here castle's whisper
was sharp even as she said it arha knew
this must be so this was the very home
of darkness the inmost center of the
light so they're in the
the under tombs which will be
illuminated later on when ged is
invading
and seeking things out and
arja is following him around
so here's what we actually learn about
what it looks like
arja saw what she had never seen
though she had lived 100 lives a great
vaulted cavern beneath the tombstones
not hollowed by man's hand but by the
powers of the earth it was jeweled with
crystals and ornamented with pinnacles
and filigrees of white limestone where
the waters under earth had worked eon
sense immense with glittering roof and
walls
sparkling delicate intricate a palace of
diamonds a house of amethyst and crystal
from which the ancient darkness had been
driven out by
glory
so this is a very beautiful cave a very
beautiful cavern that we're finding here
uh in the home of the nameless ones a
strong contrast to the oppressiveness to
the secret uh nature of the dark that
that consumes everything
else they go through the prisoner's door
they go into the under tomb they go uh
further and after they've you know seen
after they've dealt with this this area
which are has not yet seen in the light
she questions well how do we actually
get out of here you can't go back
through the door through the stone
instead there's a trapdoor that leads to
a little room as they say
behind in this warren of rooms behind
the throne room the empty throne that
signifies those powers and what we get
in this is descriptions of the fear and
uncanniness involved for our early on
right at the very beginning she doesn't
find this place something
something hospitable right and it's kind
of scary to go down in there if you get
lost you're lost for good as she says
all the tunnels were the same crossing
and re-crossing she kept careful counter
returnings and passings and recited
thar's directions to herself though she
knew them perfectly it would not do to
get lost in the labyrinth in the under
tomb and the short passages around it
castle or thara might find her or mama
manon come seeking for her
here none of them had ever been only she
herself little good it would do her if
they came to the undertone and called
aloud right
they she also says it's kind of strange
right they thar knew about the labyrinth
little about it but the name of certain
of its rooms and list of directions she
would tell these to arja but she would
never draw them in the dust or even with
a gesture of hand in the air when ara
asked her um what you know what is going
on like for example
how does the way run from the room of
bones to the tunnel by the river thar
would be silent a while and then would
tell her and one of the things that's
kind of strange about this is she'll say
you told to me before you died that this
is the case and this is where you need
to go
and what this turns into
for arja after a while
is curiosity
she wants to know all of her
domain she actually she doesn't actually
find out all of the labyrinth we find
out later in the book but curiosity and
knowledge she goes down there and traces
things out she also explores the rooms
behind the throne
and you know goes into the various
treasures
and there are three places that are
mentioned by name
within the labyrinth this maze
that um
is
there's an open iron door which she will
close on ged and trap him in there uh
about halfway through the story one is
the room of bones and we don't actually
know that much about the room of bones
we just know that it's there and there's
some sort of you know water source and
stuff like that
then there's the painted room
and the painted room has an interesting
um description there right
we find out that the
painted room does in fact
have these paintings
she liked to go
there sometimes and study the strange
wall drawings that leapt out of the dark
at the gleam of her candle men with long
wings and great eyes serene and morose
no one could tell her what they were
there were no such paintings
elsewhere in the place but she thought
she knew they were the spirits of the
damned who are not reborn right so
there's all of this interesting stuff
that's that's going on
and then we find that there's also one
very important room that
nobody's supposed to enter except for
the priestess she takes gad there
actually she has manan carry him and
then tells menan you can't go in here
wait outside the door and manan says he
but not i
and then she says if you enter this room
anon you will never leave it that is the
law for all but me no mortal being but i
has ever left this room alive will you
go in he says oh no i'll wait outside
please don't shut the door though
so she brings get in and we have an
interesting description here there were
six great chess all of stone all thick
with a fine gray dust like the mold on
bread nothing else the walls were rough
the roof low the place was cold with a
deep and airless cold that seemed to
stop the blood in the heart there were
no cobwebs
only the dust nothing lived here nothing
at all not even the rare small white
spiders of the labyrinth the dust was
thick thick and every grain of it might
be a day that had passed here where
there was no time or light days months
years ages all go on to dust this is the
place you saw it ariha said and her
voice was steady this is the great
treasure of the tombs you have come to
it you cannot ever leave it
you said you wanted to stay alive this
is the only place where i know you can
stay alive
you could have left that you couldn't
have left the tombs in any case don't
you see this is no different at least
you've come to to the end of your
journey what you sought
is here and she unchains him and says
you can't leave here so there's no point
in keeping you chained
and she tells him that she'll bring food
and water to him
in the very heart
of this labyrinth so what we have going
on here in the story
is an exploration of this domain of the
nameless ones the domain of the
priestess where she takes
ged interestingly enough
to keep him safe at least for a little
while and once we've gone into the very
heart of it and they've been in there
they'll issue fourth and that's going to
be the
last part of the story so a lot of stuff
being set in this deep
underground
subterranean
cavern labyrinth setting that plays a
very important role
in this story
you